this may not be the best acquisition
ever
but I'll be damned if it isn't up there
yeah right like I think that he bought
this I don't know that I don't know the
exact number but he bought majority of
only fans for
I think
single digit millions of dollars maybe
low double digits possibly low doubles
but let's even say it was 10 million
dollars
this is now a more than 10 billion
dollar company
[Music]
I want to start the episode with a
survey for The Listener huh and we'll
actually let John and um Ben chime in so
just Ben turn their camera on so I could
see her face all right so we're gonna
start with the survey so on Monday
morning at 7 30 a.m I wake up from a
text from Sean
and here's what the text says it goes
hey you got good topics for tomorrow I
just texted Emmett from twitch to do a
pod and he said he'll do it tomorrow so
I'm gonna drive to San Francisco
tomorrow and record an interview with
him
and so what I want Jonathan and Ben turn
your cameras on what I want you to do a
thumbs up if you think that it's the
first one a thumbs down if you think
it's the second one do you think that
this text means okay in lieu of Sam and
Sean recording together I'm gonna do one
with Emmett or do you think that this
means in addition to the recording
tomorrow I'm also going to do one with
Sam and Sean
thumbs up for the first one thumbs down
for the second one
all right great I just wanted to make
sure I'm not crazy
that's what it meant and when I heard
that I was like all right so I have some
free time between 11 and noon um ladies
and gentlemen the jury let me just say
this would I say do you have good topics
for the Pod tomorrow if we weren't gonna
do a pod with good topics together I
don't know seems like that might be
something that uh you know that we're
gonna do all right well I just want to
see what the audience thinks so whatever
um I have a bunch of topics today what
do you have I got bro you think you've
got a bunch of topics I got however many
topics you have add one that's how many
topics I got well I see a big list you
have like an interesting you have a few
interesting things what you you want to
kick us off with something let's start
with this yeah
so um we've talked a lot about one
business on this podcast probably more
than any other podcast has talked about
this business I would say we are the
champions of this company
we are the ones out here letting people
know that this company is legit that
this company is Big this company is very
interesting everybody's overlooking it
we've been saying it for years we've
been a pain customer of this company I'm
not a paying customer because I'm a
married man
but well you can be a married man do you
appreciate a customer but like I've
never paid I'm not a paying customer
because free porn exists and I'm talking
about only fans
the uh so only fans is annual numbers
leaked and um not leaked actually what
happened was actually kind of
interesting you know this but maybe a
lot of people who are listening don't
which is that any company uh that is
based in the UK has whether it's private
or public has to report at the end of
the year a sort of a financial summary
and the more the bigger your company is
the more data you have to include
basically like a like a public company
you have to report like like a public
company so
in the US if it's public you can go look
up their information maybe the quarterly
quarterly earnings or you can go find
their S1 but if it's a private company
you're just out of luck you're just
guessing but if you go to onlyfans.com
and you scroll down to the privacy
policy click privacy policy you will see
that only fans is run by a company
called Phoenix International Limited and
what is Phoenix International Limited it
is a company based in the UK so if you
go to the uh there's a a entity called
company's house and Company's house is
where uh all of the company information
is housed and so if you go there you can
find uh you can look up Phoenix
International Limited and then you can
look at filing history and you can see
that there are several reports so
reports about
uh this director replacing this director
but the what do you want to what do you
care about is the one that basically
says here is
um the 2022 Financial summary year-end
Financial summary and when you go to
that you're going to see the following
picture of a business only fans is a
business that generated or collected 5.6
billion in Revenue in 2022. its take on
that it was 20 so their their company
took 1.1 billion so for every four
dollars a Creator makes they make one
dollar
um
on that 1.1 billion in net revenue
525 million of profit so this company is
spitting off half a billion a year of
profit pay a little tax the after tax
profit is still 400 million dollars and
then the beauty of it is if you scroll
down to uh to the I don't know the
balance sheet uh somewhere down right
out right after the p l it says
dividends and it shows that the owner
Leo took 338 million in dividends last
year oh my God and a year before that he
took like 200 something million this guy
is taking out 550 million dollars of
dividends in the last two years off this
business which is just incredible
because
let me let me remind you this is a
company that he bought in 2018 this is
five years what did he uh what did he he
bought it do you know what he paid for
non-public information but he bought 75
of the business at the time
for what I believe was low millions of
dollars was he wealthy uh before that
yes so Leo is a um a kind of a gangster
of the internet and he by the way if you
just go to his website his website's
awesome so
there's really two things he's a
listener I think
well that's one of the things I love
about the website if you go to his
website which is just his name Leo Leo
radvinsky.com
um if you go to things I like so he's
got things I like and then the very
first category podcast very first one of
two podcasts is my first million so he's
a listener of the pot which was you know
just a cool thing fun fun thing to see
but I love his website because
I love when people sort of put up their
flag and they're like yo this is what
I'm all about and it's just they just
make it really easy for you to just
understand here's who I am here's what I
do here's what I'm into and if I'm into
this if you're into those same sort of
things we'll probably get along so his
his main thing says he's a software
company architect angel investor and
open source software support this guy
gives millions of dollars a year to open
source projects that probably would have
died had he not done that um he's a huge
supporter of Open Source software and
sort of like a
uh he's like you know like a sort of uh
Freedom entrepreneur right he wants
projects that are increasing the overall
amount of freedom in the universe so
whether it's uh he'll fund these open
source social networks that are like um
like a mastodon type of type of social
network that are are not owned or
controlled by like Mark Zuckerberg or
Elon Musk like one private company
closed Source owned by a mega
billionaire he's funds projects that are
alternatives to those and listen to
those also if you go to his so you see
like he has sections about me projects
open source things I like if you click
projects
only fans isn't even number one of the
listed projects it's number two number
and he it just says like one paragraph
and it says what it is but number one is
some open source project that's what he
has listed yeah before X he's like uh
b4x is like tools for rapid prototyping
and development you know Microsoft
discontinued visual Basics and before X
stepped in to try to make this happen
probably would have died you know
basically like when I looked into this
it probably would have died and then
2019 he decided to
um put a ton of money into it just so
this project could stay alive and um so
then like under giving he's like yeah I
don't I've done it a bunch of my time
effort money to cost as I care about
um including open source initiatives and
traditional Charities my goal one day is
to sign the giving pledge to sign the
giving pledge you need a billion dollar
net worth
I'm pretty sure he has like a
multi-billion dollar net worth now I
think he's achieved this goal because in
the five years and you can go look at
the company filings but like 2019 2018
the company has like he pulls out like
1.5 million in dividends
and so in like a three-year period he
went from pulling out 1.5 million in
dividends 250 and then 340 million
dollars in dividends out of this company
so this accelerated extremely quickly
and I think like you know there's all
these Great Tech Acquisitions there's
like uh you know Google buying YouTube
for a billion dollars probably worth 50
billion now Facebook buying Instagram
for a billion dollars probably worth 100
billion now
this may not be the best acquisition
ever
but I'll be damned if it isn't up there
yeah right like I think that he bought
this I don't know that I don't know the
exact number but he bought majority of
only fans for
I think
single digit millions of dollars maybe
low double digits possibly low doubles
but let's even say it was 10 million
dollars
this is now a more than 10 billion
dollar company so he turned let's just
pretend it was 10 million dollars into
essentially 10 billion dollars of value
personally not a fund not a company this
is him this is one guy who owns the
other 25 and is there a story of him
buying this and like what he saw because
like I would have if if this was me five
years ago I would have been like dude
this would never this will never work
right I mean everyone would have said
that so it was already kind of it was
already working in a very small scale so
this guy guy Stokely was the founder uh
and if you go look at guy Stokely he
looks like an Instagram model
um he's like hey uh like every picture
of him he's flanked by seven women and
uh the story is the that guy Stokely his
dad's on the finance world he takes a
small loan of like 10 000 pounds from
his dad starts only fans and
um they kind of co-owned the business or
whatever it's like a father and son was
like sort of the origin of this good
bonding yeah yeah some guys like golf
some guys like fishing
some Fathers and Sons start on the face
yeah like right like that's that's
amazing and um I don't know why he sold
or when he sold but um
uh yeah uh Leo approaches them and they
buy and he buys the business at the time
it was reported that he bought uh 75 of
the business I don't know if later he
bought the rest I suspect he did because
there's one of these filings that guy
Stokely has removed as a director in the
company so uh maybe he just voluntary
step down I don't know at some point
you're just reading a bunch into these
statements you can't say for sure
exactly how it happened and this whole
thing was very secretive in fact
when I first found out about Leo owning
only fans at the time nobody knew who
owned only fans it was not clear there's
nothing on the internet
um this was several years ago and I was
trying to figure it out couldn't figure
it out and then I get a message from
somebody who's
who's like hey I know the guy who owns
only fans and he loves the pot I was
like whoa that's cool like I've been
trying to find who owns this thing I
wanted to invest in this and um anyways
that's how we kind of like we ended up
having a chat uh you know I want to meet
this guy someday he's got a really
interesting story so
now there's like a photo of him on the
internet and there's he's a very private
guy but now a little more information
has come out about him
very early on I think when he was a
teenager like 15 16 years old
he got into the business of first I
think like domaining so he would
basically buy and sell like hundreds of
domains like maybe thousands of domains
in fact there's like a some he got sued
at some point someone there's like a
court filing of like here's a thousand
domains that this guy still owns and
it's just like every variation of uh
like you know sort of like websites that
you can imagine many of which were sort
of in the adult category
and then he creates my free cams and my
free cams basically took over the cam
girl market and
um I think that site still makes great
you know that's how I think he got very
very rich was off that site
um and he used that money then to invest
and to Parlay that into other other
businesses but he owns a portfolio of
these businesses and now
Phoenix International which is only fans
has become a major major one this is
amazing in a lot of different ways one
it's amazing that company's house it's
always a weird name I hate saying that
it's companies plural companies house
it's amazing that that exists and it's
one of my favorite places to do research
um it's amazing how fast this grew would
you
would you invest in this company or do
you not do like
yeah I tried to several times you know
the problem is they didn't need any
investment they were making so much
money and so I was like uh hey
um
I can add value and I was like I don't
even you know am I really you're
crushing it what am I going to do here
right like hey I'm a fan I think I'm a
good hang can I invest that's really
ultimately what my pitch was it's like
I'm a fan of what you're doing
um unlike most people I don't just like
you know at the time when I was saying
this stuff like oh you guys had a
it's over time become more and more
mainstream over time become more and
more accepted as a thing that's
legitimate at the time it was seen as
very
um very sketchy it was sort of the butt
of the joke and
um yeah so I definitely would have
invested in this
um I wanted to they were doing so well
that I don't think they ultimately
needed to needed any investment now the
one thing they do need is liquidity uh
like you know he's taking massive
dividends which is great but like you
know they could realize a several
billion dollar liquidity event if they
could go public or if they could sell
but there's no buyer
and it's hard to go public with a
business like this and so I think you
know I don't know what they're going to
do with it but uh you know it's not a
bad plan B to just suck out hundreds of
millions of dividends every year it's
fine yeah I was gonna say is that what
he wants I don't know why you'd ever
want to go public with it I don't know
if he wants that but you always want the
option right like any business person
will want the option whether you take it
or not is secondary in fact most of the
things in my life I'm pushing for and
people are like
do you want this and I'm like oh I
haven't even gotten there yet all I want
is the option and if I have the option
I'll then I can things what I definitely
know is I don't not want the option
right and I think that's just a better
way to operate as a business person is
to uh to make sure you have the options
on the table for you yeah 400 million
dollars a year in a dividend
there's probably only
five or ten I would imagine people
getting have who have in the world or at
least in America who have higher income
like I remember Steve Schwartzman from
Blackstone one year made a billion
dollars and then the other guy is like
what's the guy's name is it Griffith or
Griffin the uh like it's usually just
like Pam Griffin it's usually like the
top five or ten hedge fund managers who
make this and they're actually if
they're the best they're it's Fairly
reliable but they're like those are the
guys who are buying the 100 million
dollar apartments in New York you know
like the bill ackmans and there's
probably only 10 of them maybe 20 but
like that income you'd be the highest in
America in the top 30 or something like
that you know what I mean so like I
don't really I don't know man I would
probably still own that
um well this is cool well I've I've one
thing that's cool about this guy by the
way when I talk to him um like you know
80 90 of our conversation was not about
only fans at all it was about these
different open source projects he's
interested in he was just he's very like
he's a technical guy he's very curious
very interested so he was showing me
like oh by the way check this out I'm
gonna send you this link you know like
try this uh try this side out it's kind
of like it's like this Fringe Niche site
open source project but like I think
it's really cool for these reasons and
um I just love that I love you know one
of the things I love the most about tech
is that it redistributed wealth to a
bunch of people who had different
interests so like when the wealthiest
people were all from Finance
you just got this like one homogeneous
pool of rich people it's like there's a
bunch of Rich dudes that live in the
same place like the same stuff white
guys wearing suits Alpha New York
um you know power suit watch wearing art
buying greed is good come on guys yeah
and then like crypto made a whole bunch
of other people Rich right because it
was like you know a different type of
person got rich through that and they
had different interests they're like yo
I'm gonna spend money on this digital
squiggle and this board ape and I'm
gonna donate to this other thing and I'm
gonna fund these types of projects and
these types of this type of world view
I'm gonna fund and you know tech
companies were started by you know like
Mark Zuckerberg and you know this guy
didn't he wouldn't want to start a hedge
fund he wanted to do something else and
because he does that now he could spend
his money doing other things or Elon
Musk he's like I'm gonna fund companies
that will do space travel when no
investor would fund this I'll fund it
myself and so I love when wealth gets
distributed to new
pockets of people who have different
interests different values because
they're going to bring some new like
it's not the thing they created it's
actually all the stuff they do with
their money that creates 100 new new
things that's kind of interesting to me
I've uh I've emailed back and forth with
them just a few times I've asked me to
come on
um I think you have two I don't know if
that will ever happen yeah he's like I'm
a pretty private person I don't think
he's like I don't think I would make a
very good guess but
um you know well okay fine we'll talk
about your dividends then sir
you either come on as a guest or we find
you on company's house that's the rules
of this podcast dude let me tell you
about another person that is hard to
find information on and is really
fascinating but really evil have you
ever heard of the Sackler family I saw
that there's a documentary or a movie
out on Netflix about the marsh show but
I don't know anything about them so I'm
in the perfect spot I'm interested and
aware but completely ignorant so there's
two documentaries one on who or uh
they're both actually fictional shows
they're both really good one called I
think dope sick one called painkiller
one's on Hulu one's on Netflix the story
is about Purdue Pharma so Purdue Pharma
is basically I want to I'll tell you a
little bit about that and then I want to
tell you about the early even before
that because that's more interesting to
me at the at this point but basically
Purdue Pharma started by Three Brothers
they it was Mortimer Raymond and Arthur
Sackler uh they were in yeah they were
in the uh can you be named Mortimer and
not be evil like that's I mean he's and
he's one of the evil ones and so
basically these three brothers I'll talk
about their background uh in a second
but basically they were in the medical
industry forever uh since they're
starting as doctors and then they worked
at psych hospitals where they did
lobotomies and they're like all right
let's create let's start making these
medicines and drugs and so after 50
years of doing this they eventually
start or buy Purdue Pharma they buy it
for not a lot of money
um but they it evolves over 40 years to
where they create this drug called
Oxycontin
Oxycontin was basically uh it's an
opioid and it wasn't popular at the time
it was kind of unknown they had a drug
previously that was similar they kind of
changed it and they the big change they
did was they called it a Time released
technology I guess so uh and they
through a lot of just Shady practices it
seems like they've bribed the FDA they
hired lots of ex-fda people after they
approved the drug and they promised them
all this stuff they got the FDA to
approve Oxycontin and the big thing was
that they called it time release and
they said that it was believed that and
that word believe is important it's the
first time the FDA ever said that it's
believed that less than one percent of
people who takes Oxycontin will ever get
addicted so what they do is they go and
hire literally 2 000 sales people who go
to all of these hospitals these doctors
these clinics and they say hey look we
have this new drug it's for a moderate
pain it's you can use to prescribe
Vicodin only if someone had surgery and
had major pain or if they're dying from
cancer we have this new drug very few
people get addicted to it and has a Time
release capsule which means that it's
really hard to get addicted to so you
could give this to people if they just
have like a sore back or if they have
headaches like it's not that big of a
deal and they train these sales people
and they're very aggressive about
training they hold contests where you
can win a trip to Bermuda if you sell a
certain amount of drugs you can do all
these types of things where they would
give like watches they would throw
parties with hot girls like they did all
this stuff but it was for medicine
particularly in opioid which is
incredibly controversial in my opinion
very unethical and so they make
Oxycontin popular to the point where the
company is privately owned it's owned by
two families uh each the Mortimer and
Raymond's family uh I believe Raymond's
son Richard become Richard Sackler
becomes CEO and they grow this company
to be doing like 30 billion dollars a
year in revenue and they're also famous
because in order to help their
reputation they donate billions or
hundreds of millions maybe billions that
added up to two art museums and so the
met in New York they have a Sackler wing
like the the Louvre in Paris they have a
Sackler Wings they these guys never went
to Harvard but there was like in the
Harvard school or the Harvard Museum
that's for the sacklers there's the
Columbia there's the NYU like they've
donated so much of their money to arts
and it's basically what they call it a
reputation laundering so they try to
like get like into High Society even
though they're selling this drug turns
out two years ago I think
the government finally cracked down on
them made him go bankrupt and I'm not
sure where they are now but they're very
private so that's the story of Purdue
Pharma the the book Empire Payne's
really wait so sorry that the end was
the government cracks down on them and
it goes bankrupt so the government did
what because isn't oxy still like
everywhere well so what's I I'm I don't
know much about these types of drugs but
there's Oxycontin that's like the brand
name and then there's oxycodone and I
think that's the generic drug and then
there's hydrocodone and then there's
there's all these forms of opioids I
think you could still get Oxycontin but
basically at first the government made
them pay a 10 million settlement and
then people spent five years trying to
track them down and like find like one
thing that I did that broke the law
because it was very weird because they
weren't actually breaking the law or if
they were it was very hard to find which
law they are breaking because the FDA
kind of colluded and allowed them to get
away with a lot of stuff so technically
they kind of weren't breaking the law
they got hauled up in front of Congress
and what the government eventually does
is they're like oh you lied to Congress
because you said you didn't know it was
addicting but we found this email from
four years ago where you did say you
knew it was addicting and so that's
actually what they got charged with sort
of like how Al Capone got charged with
uh tax evasion not killing people it was
sort of one of those things and that led
to a domino effect where eventually they
had to pay something like an eight
billion dollar settlement the Sackler
family had to give up control of the
company and they were no longer allowed
to be involved in uh this industry and
so that's kind of where we are today
where Purdue Pharma uh it still exists
but not as it did before but we'll see
if there's any actually long lasting
change with all that but it's a it's a
really fun story like in the sense of
it's thrilling uh in that they were just
horribly unethical they did a lot of
crazy does that make sense yeah I
mean this basically killed hundreds of
thousands of people right like just
through addiction it killed hundreds of
thousands it killed hundreds of thousand
people directly in that hundreds of
thousands of people just taking that
medicine were killed but then what it
led to is what we experienced in San
Francisco and all these other places you
take oxy and then you're like I love
this I need more of it now I need
something cheaper and something more
accessible heroin and then which leads
to Fentanyl and so it creates this huge
opioid crisis where Purdue was like hey
we didn't do that we just prescribed
Oxycontin these guys are dying from
heroin when everyone's like man it's
such a clear like there's such a clear
transition here like you guys are
definitely responsible so that's why
it's like a thrilling story at Harvard
there's still this this building is
still called the Sackler or whatever the
Sackler Museum or whatever it's called
Uh still up which is kind of crazy that
they
haven't sort of canceled the the name
off the building so here's where things
get interesting and this is what I want
to talk about so I mentioned there was
three brothers only two brothers owned
Purdue so the eldest brother his name
was Arthur he died in I think uh the
late 80s or mid 80s and basically he was
the eldest brother and he got them all
into the industry when he died his
estate sold his portion of Purdue to the
other brothers and the other brothers
are the ones who Purdue eventually
created Oxycontin and so Arthur's heirs
are like look we had nothing to do with
this uh it's the same name but like we
had nothing to do with this and Arthur
was the one who liked to donate a lot of
money to museums so same last name but
their argument is that it's different
people but Arthur was incredibly shady
and I want to tell you his background
this is where things get really
interesting so check this out so this
guy Arthur Sackler he was the eldest
brother so he was a patriarch he kind of
and he brought in his two brothers into
the business and he was originally a
doctor but his first hit was as he was a
doctor he started an advertising age
agency a medical advertising agency and
he studied copywriting that was his
thing he learned about copywriting
through a traditional agency where he
would work at a traditional agency at
nights and weekends in order to help pay
the bills and he was like copywriting is
awesome I got to do this for Valium or
this other drug this other drug and so
all these huge pharmaceutical companies
at the time this was in the 50s 60s and
eventually 70s
like um what what's that big one Roche
r-o-c-h-e I believe that they were the
inventors of Valium and they start
saying Hey Arthur your little agency we
hear you have good ideas what are your
ideas he's like well we have to hire a
sales force then we're going to create
these ads we're not allowed to advertise
towards consumers but we can advertise
towards doctors and they popularize
volume by making it like an everyday
drug like oh if you're a little stressed
and you know just like you would take an
Advil pop a v you'll be calm and they
have like Housewives vacuuming in pearls
like with a Valium uh like logo or he
also popularizes his tranquilizers so he
makes them popular so he builds up this
uh agency but in secrecy he does two
things that are interesting
one he finds his competition is another
medical pharmaceutical Ad Agency and he
buys half of it and so what they what he
does is he eventually Corners the market
for pharmaceutical uh advertising and he
owns the other one secretly and he'll
say stuff like look you don't want to
work with us fine go to our competitors
they sound like they're a good fit for
you and they collude together on how to
like Market together and like which
techniques are working the second thing
that he does
is he creates this thing called the
medical Tribune it's a bi-monthly
newsletter for doctors so he's in the
newsletter industry it's a free thing a
free newsletter that is eventually read
by 300 400 500 000 doctors and he what
he does is no one knows at the time that
he owns it but he starts using his
original company MacArthur for
advertising buys ads in the medical
Tribune and through this he it creates
two huge companies and that is how he
creates his original fortune and I found
I went and like dug through the
newspapers.com that's one of my favorite
sources you can find old newspaper
clippings I found some of the numbers so
check this out so
McAdams sorry I called it MacArthur it's
called McAdams when he died the company
was doing 170 million dollars a year in
revenue and that was in 1985 I believe
uh it had 170 employees and then his
other company medical Tribune it was it
was not sold for a significant amount of
money it actually sold uh for around 70
million dollars to Axel Springer who
also bought morning Brew uh our friend
Austin's company so I've been giving
them a hard time about this
um Austin Sackler yeah for sure Austin
zachler and so annual revenues for
medical Tribune range between 50 to 80
million dollars in the last few years of
existence this was in the late 80s and
adjusted for today that's around 150 to
200 million dollars a year
he also Arthur while he was doing this
he was buying he owned like three New
York City Town Homes he was making seven
sometimes eight figure dollar donations
uh to our uh to uh museums and he had an
art collection valued at 60 million
dollars when he died I think he was 75
that was in the late 80s he was worth
around 150 million dollars which today
is around 400 million dollars maybe five
or six years after that that's when oxy
was created but besides the fact that
these guys are you know do illegal
horrible unethical things what's crazy
is this guy owned two companies that
were doing close to each of them over
100 million dollars a year and it was
medical advertising and a medical
newsletter for doctors and he owned it
was him and his wife owned the whole
thing so like super fascinating
background story uh about how this guy
originally got wealthy wow prolific
prolific family uh for sure that's crazy
that's a crazy story it's crazy so a lot
of the stuff like that the Purdue family
or the Saxon family is about it's about
oxycat and I thought that was
interesting but what I thought was
really interesting was just like I was
like well just from an entrepreneur's
perspective how to get started and so I
did all this research right dug deep and
then I went into like a I used this
thing it's like a historical money
calculator and so it helps you calculate
how much money is worth today I then
went looked at real estate prices from
the 70s and 80s in New York City and I
found out how much he was paying for
homes and I found and I basically like
reverse engineered like the income from
this medical newsletter because I was
just curious how it works I think by the
way that still works today uh and uh
there was another company I don't know
if you remember this but there was a
company that used to give out free TVs
to Doctors TV and these TVs had like
skeletons on them and you could like you
could like move the skeleton around in
order to like show like all right your
colon is actually right here and we'll
zoom in on that but on the TV was ads
for drugs and this company eventually
got in trouble interestingly enough for
fraud it turns out they were lying about
a lot of stuff but this pharmaceutical
industry is so interesting to me because
it's something that we're supposed to
trust turns out it's a lot of it's
and it's just as shady as
someone would say that this my free cams
website is or even worse and it's really
fascinating how this whole industry
works but medical newsletters super
fascinating a legit company Axel
Springer which is a five billion dollar
German newspaper company bought it and
so I actually think these still work
today and if you go on TV still running
by the way or no no they shut it down
they uh I believe they shut it down and
like everything involving sacklers like
people don't have anything to do with it
but if you um if you're on do you ever
watch cables TV yeah sometimes dude it's
only car commercials and Drug
commercials that's like all it is it's
like Cialis and like it's so anyway this
pharmaceutical advertising industry it's
I would never enter it but it's really
fascinating how it's done and it's
incredibly lucrative it created this
fortune and I think it could still
create more well I put this out there
before which was that um we get asked a
bunch about uh hey I'm doing a
newsletter can you help can you invest
can you advise whatever and we've
basically I think both of us say no to
pretty much all of them
the one that I think is interesting
still or two the two areas that I am
interested is
who's doing an amazing job of this in
real estate who's doing an amazing job
of this for the newsletter for doctors
those are the two that I really care
about and I'm like I really want to find
whoever's doing a great job of that and
uh you know invest or advise or partner
with them to like help make that bigger
because I think those spaces are
amazing spaces if you have the right
person going like doing it the right way
there's a lot of nuance to it but
um yeah I still think this idea would
just work again and they sell for huge
multiples so aging media did this for
nursing homes so someone senior living
here yeah somewhat related I I don't
remember the multiple but I heard rumors
it was like 15 times profit which is
really great uh and so these businesses
are still super lucrative and I think
what Arthur did
um whether you think that's good or bad
the way that he did it I think is bad
inherently I don't think it's bad but
the way that he did it is I think it's
still incredibly lucrative
our software is the worst have you heard
of HubSpot see most crms are a cobble
together mess but HubSpot is easy to
adopt and actually looks gorgeous I
think I love our new CRM our software is
the best HubSpot grow better
let me tell you another story about a a
smart weirdo all right so here's here's
the smartest episode smart smart weirdos
slash maybe bad people
um this guy I don't think is considered
bad but uh he's my Billy of the week
[Applause]
[Music]
a million dollars isn't cool you know
it's cool a billion dollars
Okay so we've had we have some actually
multiple contenders this is a billion of
the week
uh run off actually a a maybe this is
actually a campaign but this guy is is
um doing something interesting so his
name's Steve Davis uh you probably don't
know who that is just because it's a
fairly generic name but
um and if you Google his name it's a
it's a professional snooker player what
is that pool
yes some kind of like pool if you if you
had like you know the wrong color balls
or something
um so this guy is Elon musk's long
trusted
like right hand man so let me tell you
about this guy he um joined SpaceX back
in 2003 so very early on
um crazy background he's got a twin
master's degree in particle physics and
aerospace engineering right so you know
guy's got a dome on him and he but I
think what he was doing I think he was
doing something like completely
unrelated but he was one of the first
employees that ended up getting hired by
SpaceX for some reason I feel like I
remember he wasn't like working in the
industry he was doing something else and
then he got hired and um the stories
about this guy are kind of legendary so
when when Elon bought Twitter people
were like who's gonna uh who's he gonna
make CEO and a lot of people were like
it's going to be Steve Davis before he
put the the lady from NBC in charge
which was sort of a weird pick it seemed
like it was gonna be Steve Davis why
because Steve Davis
was living and sleeping in the Twitter
office with his wife and their newborn
child for like three weeks what a brown
noser
intense so this guy
um if you go read the stories about him
it's like it's like a folklore so uh one
person said he's been working six hours
a day every single day seven days a week
for years and years another person said
he's insane he gets more work done than
11 people working together just himself
what one time
um one time Elon Musk uh they were doing
something with the production of of a
part in in uh one of the parts of the of
the rocket I guess and this was a 120
000 part
and elon's like we need to get this down
to five thousand dollars and nobody was
everyone's like what are you talking
about like yeah of course I wish I wish
it was free too but like that's just not
how things work yeah he's like
five thousand dollars and he just left
the room right and Steve Davis takes
that as a personal challenge he's just
working for months and months to try to
figure out how can we do this for 5K
instead of 120k
he ends up getting it done for three
three thousand nine hundred dollars he
figures out a way to do it he emails
Elon so excited Elon we did it after
months we figured out how to lower the
price of this part down to only only
less than four thousand dollars you said
five we got it unless four Elon just
replies okay period
it doesn't matter Steve Davis is
undeterred from this and he he just
keeps going he's become uh now he's the
CEO of boring company so elon's like uh
you know third company or whatever that
he that he created after uh
all that right and that company's legit
right boring company they actually are
making stuff or is it just like a
t-shirt company
no they are doing things but there's a
lot of criticisms like uh
cool like how um you know how
is that tunnel going yeah right like
where's what's going on you you dug this
tunnel but like it's only compatible
with Teslas and they have to put like
rollerblades on before they go through
it's like I don't know this seems kind
of shitty right dude I want my cities to
look like swiss cheese just holes all
over the place like what's what's going
on you're just selling flamethrowers
and so you know on one hand they have
improved the speed of of boring of
actually digging the tunnels
um but the reason I found this guy
interesting so not only is he like uh
elon's right-hand man that you haven't
heard of that you know I find that
interesting uh not only is he probably
worth maybe a billion dollars at this
point like based on the SpaceX stock as
appreciated like crazy since 2003 but um
this guy's totally weird so he just is
he's got a great sense of humor that he
takes into business okay so uh he uh
basically Elon sends him Elon trusts him
right he's like hey we need somebody on
the ground in uh you know he's got like
this like city in Texas and like at one
point he sent him to DC for uh a lot
like you know they needed to be near uh
DC because a lot of their contracts are
government contracts so he's like send
Steve out to DC from California and
Steve's living there he's doing his job
but he's like God you know what I miss
I miss just having great frozen yogurt
he's like they don't have that DC he's
like all I got is this crap I missed the
California frozen yogurt you know what
so as a side job from his very important
job at SpaceX he opens up a froyo shop
called Mr yogato and he that just opens
it up he goes and he works there after
work for fun what and so he goes and he
works there and he starts to make it fun
for himself he creates just a bunch of
ridiculous policies so if you go to Mr
yogato
if you can stump him with a Seinfeld
question your froyo's free if you come
in dressed as uh Bjorn Borg or whatever
the like tennis player
or not I don't use a there's a musician
or something you get 25 off if you let
him stamp Mr yogato on your forehead 10
off and so he created this long list of
rules essentially on the secret menu
um for what he could do and then when he
had to leave he had to move away uh you
know SpaceX needed him in some other
place he's like ah I'm not gonna be
able to go work in my yogurt shop after
work uh okay
um hey come whoever comes to Mr yogato
today one of you is gonna get the shop
for a dollar and he just gave the shop
to some guy for a dollar at the end he's
like here's the keys the only rules
um I want to keep uh you know being able
to come here and eat half off and um
you know uh and also you got to keep
some of the the the the the rules alive
like if you can recite a speech from
Braveheart in a Scottish accent 20 off
and so he so he does this yogurt shop he
also at one point the the headline if
you Google Mr yogato is it's a from an
article in the Washingtonian says
Twitter's next CEO might be the Mr
yogato dude yeah
he goes bro like the rules are amazing
you just you should go look at the rules
of this rule number eight
anyone wearing a kickball uniform and
has played hard evidenced by dirt on
their knees will automatically receive
10 off their yogurt anybody who can
reenact the 47 second Michael Jackson
Thriller dance 20 off if you perform a
shorter choreographed dance you can get
10 off
actually genius by the way order a yoga
for 30 consecutive days and we'll name
them a flavor after you I mean this
guy's awesome yeah so he's having a good
time so then he opens up a bar called
Thomas Foolery short name tomfoolery and
same things uh instead you know every
bar has a happy hour he created the
angry hour where if you shout your order
of the drink to the bartender angrily
you get a discount on your drink
um you know they served like cookies and
ice cream at this thing and he's like
this is a place where we're going to
take you back to being a kid but with
alcohol
oh my God and I was like dude I love
this guy this guy is uh hilarious and
weird and all the best ways and I just
went down this rabbit hole because his
this guy kind of fascinates me there's
nothing about this guy really on the
internet nobody does interviews with him
um
people discovered this mystery Elgato
thing but there's not much out there
about him how'd you find that there's
only a few times
uh that's like you know part you know
just digging in like what are some of
the other craziest things that this guy
does when they announced um the boring
company it was a press conference with
Elon and some guy the some guy is Steve
Davis sitting next to him during the the
talk and what they did was to make their
points I I kind of love this marketing
to make their point that like why did
you create the boring company and he was
like well
in like whatever 100 years we haven't
gotten any faster at drilling like we're
still the same speed we were like 50 75
years ago at digging these tunnels
nobody's done anything Innovative and to
do when they did the press conference
it's them talking but around them is a
circular track and on that track they
put us little like a snail or a slug or
something and it was just walking around
the track super slowly to represent how
slow this industry is and how slow other
people are Drilling and at the end of
the two hour seminar it was still only
halfway around the thing oh my God and
they're like you know that's the
industry today and we're gonna change it
I love these little nuggets these little
sort of like marketing gimmicks that
make a point in the sort of simplest
most uh memeable viral way possible uh
you know I Gotta Give Elon credit and uh
this guy Steve Steve credit for how they
do that where where did you work before
how do you get a job with Elon uh well
just early on you know if your twin
master's degree in particle physics and
aerospace engineering there's not that
many places to go work you work in NASA
or you work you know uh Boeing or you go
work here right so he got a job there
early on and just like
started grinding like crazy and that's
why like even now just sort of grinds
like crazy sleeping in the office with
the with his newborn the child that was
just like his wife just just gave birth
I have a rule we have a rule in our
house in the in the par house where I
will only sleep under another man's roof
for one night and if it's my father if
it's my father-in-law's house he gets
two nights I don't like sleeping in
another man's home it's the most
emasculating thing on earth I can't
imagine
moving my wife and newborn baby into the
Twitter office can you move to my boss
now yeah my boss's house like elon's
like hey how's our wife doing like
you're like a billionaire yeah you're
not like an intern
yeah you're you're like I I don't even
like I don't stay at another man's house
I don't even like staying at my father's
law's house let alone staying at the
Twitter HQ can you imagine with a
newborn with a newborn or a baby I can't
imagine that that's not for me dog
what's your phrase cornrows and face
tattoos yeah it's not for me but I'm
glad freaks like you exist yes but God
it exists sleeping at the office with my
wife and baby you got you can have that
I'm happy you exist but that ain't for
me is there any part of you that is
envious of this guy because I don't find
any amount of Envy other than I
appreciate his sense of humor oh yeah I
think this guy is great I think uh do I
want to be him no that's what I mean do
I think that this guy's probably you
know this guy's interesting and it seems
like he uh thinks differently and I
think I could learn or be inspired by it
sure for sure for example I went deep uh
so one so one of the things he did while
he was working at SpaceX and they moved
him to DC in addition to the yogurt shop
he went to George Mason and got like a
PhD and his thesis I found his thesis
paper and I read it
which was very hard I don't want to go
into too much detail on it how did you
find this when I'm Googling him I can't
you can barely find anything it's the
same like four photos just a lot of grit
determination you're the Steve you're
the Steve Davis Steve Davis
exactly I applied to searching
researching other great men more so than
being one myself slept under a couch for
literally hours to find this it was
literally I ignored
[Laughter]
so I'm just gonna read you two things so
first of the paper the reason I really
liked it is it's about the debasement of
the US currency I think he wrote this in
uh what year was this
it's basically like very or it's very
early it's that kind of like early
Bitcoin days so let me just search Steve
Davis
basement
um
so yeah 2010 and his paper is called the
trend towards the debasement of the
American currency and he talks does that
mean is that the bottom does that mean
devaluing so so you know he he talks
about the history of like you know
basically uh you know I don't have my
notes in front of me now but like uh one
of the things he talks about is
you know um did you take notes on this
one just for yourself
yeah
um so I was like you know he's like one
dollar or whatever you know one or so
one ounce of gold was worth this many
dollars before and now that same ounce
of gold requires whatever like you know
100 x more dollars like basically like
we used to be Peg to Gold we got off the
gold standard and look at how look at
how much the dollar is devalued relative
to gold in that time and he's basically
like there's a trend towards the
debasement of um
of currency and he talks about like
people think this is like a you know
overtime slow slow thing but actually
like 95 of the debasement has just
happened in the last like 40 50 years or
something like that uh like it has
accelerated quickly and this is not just
like uh yeah this is not just like you
know a slow thing
um all right here we go so 98.3 has
occurred from 19 1792 to the present
time but even if you shorten that like
still 90 of it happened in a very short
window of time he talks about why he
talks about how he talks about like what
that why that's such a big problem and
this is basically like a a
cryptocurrency like
you're not talking about Bitcoin in it
but this is like this is crypto is a
solution to this problem right like
Bitcoin
could not be debased exactly uh which is
like the meme but it's it's also like
uh the truth you know it's like these
things are cliche because they're
there's an element of Truth and then
that's why they stick around in his
acknowledgments in this paper so he says
oh I want to I want to thank this
professor or this professor I want to
thank this person and at the end he's
like I want to thank my mom and dad he's
like finally thanks to the unknown Chef
that makes great brownies at the small
Enterprise Hall cafeteria hopefully they
will one day become a topping at Mr
yogato or its successor little yo-hai
this guy's just hilarious man this guy
is just so funny to me and uh yeah
there's like 100 page paper if you want
to go read the most impressive part is
that you read this guy's thesis paper
and you've got as far as to the
acknowledgments at the end no no
acknowledgment's at the beginning was
for my friend that's like the uh the
thank you at the beginning of a book uh
so I didn't read the whole thing there's
162 page thesis I've read like 40 pages
maybe uh step by step step by step where
the debasement started it and how it
happened and I'm like oh wow this is
fascinating like I never knew any of
this is that we have to do to become a
PhD is to write a 140 page like original
work on something that's amazing I
didn't think I didn't know that thesis
were that long not only do we not have a
PhD we honestly don't even know what the
hell a PhD is or what it takes to get
one I used to tell people I had my PhD I
thought I meant poor hardworking and
driven uh like that was my joke I I play
a hate and degree yeah I didn't realize
that it's you have to write a hundred
plus page like report on this that's
amazing I'm not that hungry and driven
yeah yeah definitely not that sounds
really challenging uh by the way one of
the great get to know you questions in
the business world that's sort of dorky
but actually is a good one which is if
you had to give an impromptu 45 minute
talk on a subject what would you give it
on like for you it might be like
copywriting or newsletters right like
something like that the history of denim
what
I'm not joking I could do it
you want to talk about denim I got you
what would yours be
there is no answer that is better than
that answer I don't want to continue the
podcast
[Laughter]
the things about looms is in the
previous yeah
shadow looms pre-1944 were particularly
special but no I could talk all about it
and then post-war what Japan was
rebuilding Hiroshima they needed just a
ton of machinery and that's what the
shutter looms of America went to Japan I
mean I could do it that's insane all
right your your turn what's your topic
where do we go from here
um you want to do Post pilot I like post
pilot all right let's talk about I
invested in post pilot did you yeah me
too
um I didn't you know I don't like as you
call it talk in your own book too much I
don't like talking about stuff that I'm
involved in but since we're both
involved about it and we're up front we
could talk about it we'll explain what
it is first yeah so let's talk about it
so our connection to post pilot is with
the owner his name is Drew but he
actually bought the company and the
reason he bought the company was because
he owned um he used to buy software
company so he bought design and
public.com he bought he bought
karmaloop.com and then he owned this
thing called AutoAnything which was an
auto parts store and the thing about uh
his whole like Playbook is that he would
buy these uh time companies and he would
be like well your email list stinks so
we can like improve that we could do
this we can do that and one of the
things that he used to do with these
companies that worked really well was he
would email or mail them like snail mail
them like flyers and Direct Mail
pamphlets on the company however it was
really hard to do it was like a
painstaking process and so he bought
this company called post pilot he bought
it I think he bought it for sixty
thousand dollars and what it does is if
you're a Ecom brand you just sign up to
post pilot and they plug in I think to
Shopify to woocommerce to like a lot of
the popular platforms and they have a
done for you service meaning they'll
help you design a pamphlet that you
could send to not only your customers
but I think some of your email
subscribers and people who haven't
already bought from you and they can
send direct mail in a click of a button
and so what he has found like this whole
thesis is like look
if I have an email list and some of
these companies that I bought their
email list was a hundred thousand people
but ninety thousand people wouldn't even
open the email ten thousand would but
how do I get the other 90 000 people to
interact with me well let's just send
them mail and so they created a process
that you can use someone's address that
they've already supplied to or I believe
what they do is you can um you can use
someone's email and phone number and
help use other data sources to find out
roughly where you live and they'll send
mail to you or that area or people who
match your it's like a look-alike
audience and they send you mail and they
could track if you eventually bought
something through their mail so it's a
very Roi positive business
Roi positive marketing channel and I
think he bought this company in 2018. he
bought it for 60 Grand it's making well
over 60 Grand a day now I think that the
last the the public information that
they said was they crossed 10 million a
year in Revenue uh like 18 months ago I
think and it's growing like a weed and
he sends amazing investor updates uh
where like there'll be like a theme so
for example him and his co-part or him
and his partner sent an update where it
was him and his partner dressed like
Step Brothers uh and so like he does
these really funny updates but the
business is growing like a weed it's
growing crazy and they're um it's really
fascinating is that what what I'm not an
econ guy is that what you what yeah so
we use it so so we use it and like you
know if you do advertise on Facebook or
you advertise on Google and you know the
key metric for any eCommerce brand is
your return on ad spend uh when it comes
to marketing so you spend 100 on ads
what's your return are you gonna get 100
back you're gonna get 200 back and get
fifty dollars back fifty dollars would
be a point five percent on ad spend 200
would be a 2.0 uh original announcement
you can be like getting a 2.0 return on
ad spend at scale you're printing money
right yeah you're putting in 100 you're
getting 200 out every single day and um
that's uh you know obviously if you
could scale that up that's that's
extremely extremely lucrative
if you use postpilot you can get like a
10x return on ad spend it's not the most
scalable but it is pretty ridiculous the
type of return you get he said a lot of
people are getting 5 to 10x
um he said most retention campaigns come
in between five and ten five and ten uh
so like he kills it they I don't use it
yeah these are these are like retention
right so you're you know you're trying
to get uh people to come back or you're
trying to get a warm lead who hasn't
bought from you but they gave you their
their info to try to convert so it's you
know obviously different for a
completely new customer versus returning
customer versus whatever but the Blended
uh row as for these is really really
good so it's very effective right you
send a postcard it's got a bunch of it's
got a photos he's got photos on it it's
got an offer on it and uh the cool thing
what they did was they basically took
this they weren't the first to do you
know how do you send mail campaigns
we'll send it for you what they did was
they're treating it like it's clavio so
most people outside of e-comers don't
even know about clavio except for the
fact that it just filed to go Publix and
now a bunch of people are paying
attention to this like 10 billion dollar
company that raised very little money
email marketing for
um for e-commerce actually it didn't
raise the very little it raised 400
million it only Burns sorry net 15
million dollars which shows how Capital
efficient that's what I mean yeah sorry
um so every econ brand basically uses
clavio at this point
um it is like the the the dominant
player in the space there's some others
like send lane or whatever but they
basically said we're gonna automate this
so like we will take all your Co your
customer data from Shopify and we'll be
like cool
um when somebody first joins we'll put
make a welcome flow so automatically
it'll drip out like one hour after they
do after they sign up for emails they'll
get this three days later with a look at
this later they'll get that clavio yeah
yeah and now what postpile did was they
took the same thing they're like cool
you want to send a one-off blast you can
just go in our editor and do that you
want to create automated flows that are
just going to be triggered based on
customer Behavior you can do that too so
they basically did for physical mail the
same thing that clavio did for digital
mail which is very very smart
um so yeah anyways I think they're
they're doing really well and we'll see
kind of how how big I think the only
question of this one is just how big
does it get it's a high floor
unknown ceiling so it's like uh this
business is definitely gonna work now
the question is working is it a yeah
even when we first invested it was like
this clear this was gonna work and it
was a delicious it was a low valuation
compared to everything it was not low it
was a reasonable valuation compared to
everything else I think I have about 25
Grand in the company yeah I did
something similar it was it wasn't it
wasn't like you know massive massive bet
but um you know the question is is this
gonna be a 50 million business 100
million dollars it's a 500 million
dollar business or a billion dollar
business I have no idea on that one like
we'll see but um but it's definitely
like it was like a clear this isn't
going to be a zero type of investment so
I did this one personally not out of the
fun because I was like you know you
don't know the profile of this one I
thought so I have 25 000 of my own money
into the company I think I uh in my head
when I was looking at it I was like I
think the the the likely worst case
scenario is that this will sell for 70
or 80 million dollars I was like I think
I could 5x 4X my money I think in a
unlikely but High
outcome scenario I was like many many
hundreds of millions of dollars this
could sell for uh and I could for sure
100 10x this maybe more
um that right that that was kind of my
thinking with that investment and 25 000
of my own money is I I usually do small
small checks that's a smaller checks
that's a that's a good one for me right
on
um I have some other topics but I think
we should save them one thing I want to
do is I want to start doing episodes
that are business ideas only so
sometimes but basically if you take an
episode of my personality you kind of
don't know what you're gonna get there's
a box you might get a billy of the week
story about crazy people who have done
crazy things you might get a business
breakdown like we did with only fans
just like here's a business here's the
numbers here's how it's doing uh maybe
it's a business like post pilot like a
business you never heard of that's doing
really well
um we're kind of expose you to the sort
of uh things that are under under the
radar not not on your radar
and then sometimes we do ideas and
opportunities things that we think
people could do
that could be that could work and um
Monday I say I proposing this to you
Monday I think we should do uh when we
record Monday we should do business
ideas only I think uh I think we're good
Monday and I have a good one which are
people's favorites that the business
ideas and opportunities there's
definitely people's favorites
um so we'll do that
but you know if we're gonna do that
people got to do something for us right
like I don't know about you but if I
kiss I like to get kissed back if I
hugged back and if I provide value I
like to get value Yes means yes
and all we need from you to give value
back put your wallet away you know we
don't it doesn't take money it's not
free though it ain't free it ain't free
it sure as hell ain't free but but your
money's no good here
what we do need is for you to take that
little finger of yours open up the
podcast app click subscribe
go to my first building click subscribe
the next thing you're gonna do where do
they do that YouTube where do they do
that they do on Spotify any Spotify
Apple podcast whatever whatever is your
comfortable place I'm not trying to get
you to go somewhere you're not
comfortable right go where you're
comfortable well just make sure you're
click and subscribe Now go to YouTube
go open YouTube
type in my first million click subscribe
hit the little bell so you get alerts we
need both of those things from you we
just need it
and I don't ask for much but I ask for
this
don't let me down and if you want leave
a comment you could leave a comment we
read all of them and we even the
funniest ones we send to each other
particularly if they make fun of us
yeah the most insulting ones definitely
get the most attention and uh we can't
resist we're not one of those we're not
those people who are like nah I don't
read the comments I don't read the
haters read all of them yeah I think
about you and I recognize usernames
you're living in our head yes I've
Googled some of these people I do a
reverse Google image search and find out
they're LinkedIn
and here I'll actually leave uh I'll
leave like a hint so
for next Monday you you can see on here
which company I'm talking about if you
scroll down so I was going to start this
with a business that used to exist that
was way ahead of its time that I think
should exist today now is the time now
is the time if you could possibly pull
this off you agree with me do you see
what company I'm talking about I know
what you're talking about I agree with
you I can't wait to talk to you about
that one and I have one that is
um
similar to
one of the best businesses in Andrew
Wilkinson's portfolio
and I think you could create a new
version of that that would work really
well that's the teaser all right Manic
Monday we'll call it I don't know we'll
just go from ideas to ideas or where we
just look at the comments and just
stress out over like blemishes we have
on our face but it's Manic Monday
so you don't have to pay money for this
show but it ain't for free and and you
know how you know how to pay for it so
all right that's the part
[Music]